طبعا المشاهدين عاده ما يعرف جمهور كل
فريق او منتخب بانه اللاعب رقم 12 لكن
الجمهور المغربي وخلال المونديال الحالي
كسر القاعده اثبت انه اللاعب رقم 1 مش 12
ففي موعد تاريخي سيقف منتخب المغرب على
اعتاب نهائي اغلى المسابقات الكرويه حاملا
فوق عاتقه امل جماهير بلاده وايضا جماهير
عربيه واخرى افريقيه منذ انطلاق مونديال
قطر لكره القدم كانت كلمه السر بالنسبه
لاسود الاطلسيه الجمهور المغربي الذي
تزايد زخمه مع التاهل لدور الثمن ثم ربع
النهائي واليوم في المباراه المصيريه التي
ستجمعه بنظيره الفرنسي الاسود يخططون
لمواصله المغامره الموندياليه وحجم مكان
في النهائي معاولينا طبعا على الجماهير
العريضه التي كان لديها دور كبير في
نجاحات المنتخب المغربي والتي اثبتت كما
ذكرنا بان برقم واحد في تشكيله وليد
للرجيم منذ بدايه المونديال من المتوقع
حضور اكثر من 20,000 مشجع مغربي بعد ان
خصصت الرباط جسرا جويا لنقل انصار المنتخب
المغربي الى الدوحه طبعا اضافه للالاف من
العرب والافارقه الذين من المتوقع ان
يساند اسود الاطلس وفقا لارقام احصائيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
طبعا مشاهدينا الصور التي نشاهدها الان في
هذه اللحظات هي صور مباشره تاتينا من
الدوحه حيث هذه المباراه طبعا الكل
ينتظرها هذه صور مباشره من احدى نقاط
التشجيع وطبعا الاعلام المغربيه جمهور
المغرب يتواجد في هذه النقطه تحديدا
[موسيقى]
طبعا مشاهدينا حضور جماهيري لمباريات
المغرب كان لافت جدا نبدا بالمباراه التي
جمعت اسود الاطلس مع نظيره البرتغالي فيها
تجاوز عدد المشجعين عدد ثبت ال 44 الف
اغلبهم طبعا مشجعين المنتخب اما في
المباراه التي كانت مع المنتخب الاسباني
فلقد زاد عدد المشجعين عن
44,500 مشجع اغلبهم ايضا من انصار اسود
الاطلس المنتخب المغربي يتمتع بخط دفاع
قوي حيث لم تتلقى شباكه هو هدف واحد طبعا
جاء خطا في مرمى كما انه حافظ على نظافه
شباكه في اربع مباريات من اصل الخمس
مباريات خاضها لحد الان سجل المنتخب
المغربي خمسه اهداف في البطوله بينما وقع
نظيره 11 هدفا انطلقت شباكه اربع اهداف
كما انه تلقى الهزيمه في مباراته الثالثه
امام المنتخب التونسي علما انه كان متاهل
فبعد الانجاز غير المسبوق ببلوغ المربع
الذهبي يمكن للمغرب ان يعول على دعم قاره
باكملها يحمل امالها من خلال تحدي اصحاب
اللقب السابق للوصول الى النهائي في عالم
الساحره المستديره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]